hey guys let's talk about sex Yes you
heard me right let's talk about sex and
for all of those of you who might be
surprised or shocked that I'm going to
talk about sex let me just make this
clear
the whole world is talking about sex
in magazines in books
on social media
in entertainment
in school they talk about it and most
kids hear about it from their friends at
school many years too early
so let me ask you why should Christian
preachers not talk about sex
and why are others not doing it because
they are scared of what people will say
because we as true Christians children
of God and especially preachers we need
to talk about these things in truth and
in love and let me tell you this the
Bible has a great deal to say about sex
for example
Proverbs 5 Verse 18 let your fountain be
blessed and rejoice in the wife of your
youth
a lovely deer a graceful dough let her
breasts fill you at all times with
delight be intoxicated always in her
love
wow is this the Bible yes it is the
Bible a lot of people don't even know
this the Bible talks a lot about sex
and you know John the Baptist
he did not keep quiet about sex he spoke
the truth
and he was beheaded because he would not
compromise on God's moral law
and we should do the same we should not
be fearful we should speak the truth in
boldness but also in love
so today I'm gonna be straight with you
guys
and because we are men we need to talk
about these things
I'm going to be frank about sex we're
going to take a look at scripture and
we're going to talk about sex what the
Bible says about sex in a healthy way
first you need to understand that God
created sex for good not for evil
and you can see that back in Genesis God
blessed Adam and Eve and told them in
Genesis 1 verse 28 be fruitful and
multiply and fill the Earth
in other words he told them have sex
have children it was meant for good
there was nothing strange or shameful
about it lustful in a sinful way no it
is meant to be good and honorable within
marriage
Hebrews 13 verse 4 let marriage be held
in honor among all
and let the marriage bed be undefiled
for God will judge the sexually immoral
and adulterous
you know God gave us the desire to have
sex and just think about it if if he
didn't you know we would cease to exist
we would not have sex we would not have
any children and we would just die out
and I agree with bully Graham who said
that God gave man
kind three main reasons to have sex
one to propagate the human race two for
the climax of true love within marriage
and three sex was given so that a man
and a woman could express the unity
between them and you can enjoy sex
within marriage as we read in Proverbs
enjoy your wife
but if that is the only reason you want
to have sex is just because of fleshly
desire there's something wrong
because that's what the world is making
sex out to be today just for one reason
and that is just lust
it is for selfish pleasure and in a lot
of cases they just use the other person
as a prop not a human being
listen carefully
yes God has given you
the desire to have sex but with this
desire comes a responsibility
to have self-control
and if you cannot control yourself then
what makes you different from an animal
that just led by its emotions just wants
to have sex whenever it wants to
you're a human being made an image of
God
and if you don't have self-control if
you don't take responsibility for your
own actions then you're
a weak and selfish man
one Thessalonians 4 verse 3 says for
this is the will of God
your sanctification
that you abstain from sexual immorality
that each one of you know how to control
his own body in Holiness and honor not
in the passion of lust like the Gentiles
who do not know God
you know a lot of men they have the
wrong perception or understanding of
what sex really is
and it is not only
wrong it is dangerous because it causes
a lot of pain and suffering in the world
and that is why we need to talk about
this truthfully
first I said sex is not bad God created
it to be enjoyed within marriage and
second it can be used for evil and when
you look at the world it is mostly used
for evil
a lot of men today they even boast about
their idolatry as if it's some kind of
achievement
they have no honor
Proverbs 6 32 says he who commits
adultery lacks sense
he who does it destroys himself
any form of sex outside of marriage
is wrong
and when you do it adultery it's not
just causing harm to you like this verse
says in Proverbs it is also causing harm
to your family it destroys families
let me ask some of you how many of you
had a dad who cheated on their mom you
found out
how did you feel about it
remember it and don't do it to your
family
Genesis 2 verse 24 says therefore a man
shall leave his father and his mother
and hold fast to his wife
not wives not Other Woman
your wife
and they shall become one flesh
another danger within marriage is also
this
a lot of people give in to temptation
when the Temptation is strong and their
self-control is weak when they act in
the flesh then they sin and that usually
happens when they feel that they're not
being fulfilled in the marriage for a
long period of time and then they start
looking at the other side of the grass
and the grass looks Greener but it's not
it's actually rotten
1 Corinthians 7 verse 5 says do not
deprive one another
except perhaps by agreement for a
limited time
that you may devote yourselves to prayer
but then come together again
so that Satan may not tempt you because
of your lack of self-control
you know as a man as the head of the
family you need to make a point I mean
make effort to keep that spark in your
relationship alive take care of your
body eat healthy work out have sex and
enjoy it
do you see
your desires not just with sex but with
all desires when it comes to
relationship with your wife you know and
with sex you need to be filled inside of
marriage so that
you don't go and look for it at other
places
because let me tell you you won't find
it
and you know this is important because
the number one thing that men struggle
with the number one sin is lust
and if you look at a history
even Kings it doesn't matter who you are
what type of man you are most men when
you look at a history
the one thing that brought men down to
their knees
was women
Adam who was tempted to sin by Eve in
Genesis 3.
Abraham by Sarah in Genesis 16.
Samson by Delilah in judges 16.
and the young man by a harlot proverbs
7.
and then also Joseph by Potiphar's wife
I'm mentioning Joseph because Joseph was
one of the few men who did not give in
to temptation
and at that moment it wasn't even good
for him because he was put in prison
but God used that situation for good and
at the end he put him in a power
position so that he could help the
nation of Israel do you see what I'm
saying here
a lot of men are struggling
they fail they fall into temptation
and they cheat on their partners and
then they destroy their family and when
we look at society today we see that
there are broken
we are broken Society is broken because
of broken families
and a lot of them are broken not even by
real women
or women on pictures and videos because
they're addicted to pornography
God's word says in one Corinthians 6 18
flee from sexual immorality every other
sin a person commits is outside the body
but the sexually immoral person sins
against his own body
now this is extremely serious for God
he is very clear on sexual sin in the
Bible and you need to understand this
because part of the reason I'm making
this series is because when we look at
the world what is going on is getting
worse
you see the devil and his demons pulling
the strings of secret societies and
leads who control big corporations the
media entertainment even trying to
control the schools so that kids young
kids think that they are uncool if they
reach the age of 16 and they're still a
virgin
then I've been making fun of
we are getting worse over time because
it used to be
18. it used to be 21 before 18.
do you see what I'm saying here
and now we have even kids 10 year old
kids who are becoming pregnant
the world is changing as we know it you
think I'm joking I'm not watch this
now the department said that 23 000 teen
girls that had fallen pregnant some as
young as the age of 10. wow now this
figure is out from April 2020 to March
13 year old Virginia has her hands full
trying to comfort her three-month-old
baby tending to house chores and her
four younger siblings
she was 12 when she became pregnant
a few months ago Lorena's life was
turned upside down
at 15 she became a mother
ever since she and her boyfriend have
faced constant challenges and are
raising their daughter Andrea in an
abandoned building
she's a baby but I'm just a child too I
should have stayed at school you know
this is one of the reasons why God is
against sex before marriage because a
lot of men today without a backbone
men without values without character
integrity
they make a woman pregnant and then they
just run away
but it is their responsibility to take
care of that child
there is a fatherless crisis in the
world and we men
are to blame
watch this
sixty percent of South Africa's children
have absent fathers more than 40 percent
of South African mothers are single
parents
single her mother would the single
as a
standing four percent today I'm guessing
there will be no committee hearings
about that
there are more black babies born there
are more black babies aborted than born
alive in cities like New York and you
have Democrat Governor Andrew Cuomo
lighting up buildings to celebrate late
term abortions
you know an absent father causes a lot
more harm that he would ever realize
and listen to me today
if you know that you have a child
somewhere go and make it right
and if some of you are watching and you
just fathered a child then take
responsibility if you're scared that
you're not a good enough father then
learn become better let God change you
because you can't change through Christ
who gives you strength
and changing start review taking
responsibility for your actions
according to the U.S Census Bureau
18.4 million children
one in four live without a biological
step or adoptive father in
[Music]
fatherless societies affect the whole
world and increases the crime even I
already told you that around 60 percent
of the children in South Africa grow up
with absent fathers let me show you how
that impacts the crime according to
worldpopulationreview.com South Africa
has the third highest crime rate in the
world
South Africa has a notably High rate of
assaults rape
homicides and other violent crimes
South Africa has one of the highest rape
rates in the world more than one in four
men surveyed by the South African
medical research Council admitted to
committing rape
you see fatherlessness is one of the
highest causes of crime in the world
causing the most pain and suffering and
people can even imagine
and why is nobody talking about this
here and there some people are talking
about it but the mass media definitely
not why not
why not deal with the problem facts over
feelings yes feelings are important but
facts are more important and facts don't
care about feelings what I mean is if
you go to the hospital and you say man I
have a headache help me and he's like
nah here's just some pills so you can
feel better it doesn't cure the problem
you might need a surgery if you don't
get it you will die
we need to talk about facts listen to
this the U.S department of health
statistics shows that fatherlessness
causes the following 63 percent of Youth
suicides ninety percent of all homeless
and runaway children
85 percent of all children who show
behavioral disorders eighty percent of
rapists with anger problems 71 of high
school student dropouts 75 percent of
adolescent patients in chemical abuse
centers 85 percent of youths in prison
and 71 of pregnant teenagers
look at all of these statistics causing
so much pain and suffering oh yeah but
it's cool to brag about how many women
you slept with you are the man right
a real man takes care of his family
he doesn't run away from his
responsibilities a week
and pathetic man does watch this from a
former gang leader an increasing number
of sickeningly violent crimes is being
committed by America's youth
why is this happening is it a spill
problem
breakdown problem is it a cultural
problem policing problem or is it a
combination of all of them
well the stories the criminality seems
to be getting worse two Iowa teens have
just been accused of killing their 66
year old high school Spanish teacher
with a baseball bat
in Minneapolis earlier this month a 17
year old was charged with shooting and
killing a man while he sat in his car at
a gas station
and last month a 19 year old was
arrested for the murder of a
nine-year-old girl there authorities
have traced most of these frightening
cases to teens as young as 13.
joining me now is John turnip seed
former gang leader drug dealer and pimp
he's also the Executive Vice President
of Urban Ventures John why is this
happening you're based in Minneapolis we
always think of Minnesota nice but
what's driving the violence
well one of the things this is sort of
the aftermath of George Floyd you know
when that happened and all the
lawlessness came in
kids got a sense of empowerment
and you know all of a sudden we're
backing off you know arresting people
for certain things and things of that
nature well kids you know who have a
rebel spirit in them anyways a lot of
times take advantage of this and now
it's it's sweeping the country and kids
will follow trends at one time we had
kids that would knock people out see if
they could knock people out with one
blow this is not funny
where are all the fathers
men training boys to become men of good
character
where are you
why do you just leave your boys alone
that is just pure evil
and if you're still alive and if your
boys are still alive there's still time
to make this right
non-linking fatherlessness with sex
because no one is talking about this and
the two are connected
because it seems like we as a society as
the human race we're not taking
responsibility
the decisions we make and the
consequences that comes from those
decisions
you get weak men who don't care about
the consequences they just want to have
sex and pleasure just so selfish
self-centered and then they just run
away they have one night stance and they
impregnate women and then they just
leave them alone
how can you just vanish like that
what is wrong with you
on entertainment you always see shows
where a group of guys is going out and
having a competition of who can get laid
it is all about sex pleasure and no
responsibility that comes with it
guys listen up it is easy just to give
in to your sinful flesh right your
sexual desires it is easy and that's why
it doesn't make you cool or the man
because anyone can do it but it takes a
good man of character to discipline
himself to have self-control
the Bible says in 2 Timothy 2 verse 22
so flee youthful passions and pursue
righteousness Faith love and peace along
with those who call on the Lord from a
pure heart
and remember 1 Corinthians 6 18 says
flee from sexual immorality every other
sin a person commits is outside the body
but the sexually immoral person sins
against his own body
it doesn't say be led by your sinful
desires it says flee
don't walk closer and inspect it and
play around with it it says flee that
means turn around and run especially
when it comes to women sex
wait for the right woman and then you
can have as much sex as you want and
enjoy it within marriage and if you want
to stay single then you can do that but
if you are burning with desire
and you know this is the woman God wants
you to marry then do it
Paul says in 1 Corinthians 7 verse 8 to
the unmarried and the widows I say that
it is good for them to remain single as
I am but if they cannot exercise
self-control they should marry for it is
better to marry than to burn with
passion
the world says have as much sex as you
want before marriage yeah you can get
AIDS yeah you can get children and yeah
there's a lot of problems that can come
with it but just do what you want no
consequences that's what the world feels
and things and you see it on TV all the
time and it's it's gross
the Bible says no
we want healthy societies men of
character woman for character
who have sex inside marriage and we take
care of their children a healthy family
there is a reason why you don't want to
have sex with a lot of women before
marriage because you're gonna carry
those experiences with you into the
marriage with all that baggage you're
gonna go in the marriage and for a lot
of men it is hard they struggle with it
those memories
1 Corinthians 7 verse 1. now concerning
the matters about which you wrote it is
good for a man not to have sexual
relations with a woman but because of
the temptation to sexual immorality each
man should have his own wife and each
woman her own husband the husband should
give to his wife her conjugal rights and
likewise the wife to her husband
if you're not married yet then please
listen to me as a married man I've been
married for 13 years and I spoke of a
lot of other men who's been married for
longer than me
and the advice that we're going to give
you is not just ah stupid old people no
this is important because a lot of
people make the same mistakes and you
can never go back and change it
you can ask God for forgiveness right
but you can't change it you've done it
so we're telling you these things so you
don't make the mistakes
because when you are married later you
will regret it not just because it is
wrong but because those memories and
experiences can be a problem for your
marriage
because you take that baggage with you
also think about it this way do you want
to marry a woman you've not slept with
any woman but she slept with a lot of
guys
how does that make you feel right now
not good right you don't feel good about
that
and there's a lot of you men that want
to sleep with a lot of women right and
then you want to marry a woman who's not
slept with
other guys does that make sense to you
you need to be pure as well
the reason because it feels dirty when
you think about those things inside is
because God has given all mankind a
moral code inside of them you know what
is right and what is wrong
it's actually disgusting because sex is
not just a physical Bond it is a
emotional and spiritual union that is
why if you sleep with a Satanist those
demons can go into you as well it
happened when I was younger my dad
prayed for a woman that exactly that
happened to her every time the husband
will come back from a truck driving she
would just attack him they didn't know
what was going on they prayed for them
and the demon manifested sex is not just
oh it's going to be sex no it's much
more than that it is sacred God created
it between a man and a woman within
marriage
and marriage is to be held in honor
among all things
look when it comes to sex the Bible
makes the following very clear
number one sex before marriage is wrong
two sex outside of marriage is wrong
three sex with an animal is wrong
four rape is wrong five sex with close
relatives is wrong six same sex is wrong
thinking about any of the above and
imagining how you do it is wrong
good
you know sex is so sacred marriage is so
sacred and that's why Jesus said it's
not just about what you do it's about
what you think your intentions
you said in Matthew 5 verse 27 you have
heard that it was said
you shall not commit adultery
but I say to you that everyone who looks
at a woman with lustful intent has
already committed adultery with her in
his heart
and yes this includes pornography
this includes masturbating and let me
make this very clear
marriage
is amazing if it's done within the will
of God if the man is a godly man if the
woman is a Godly woman you'll have an
amazing time and the sex is also great
you can have sex within marriage and
enjoy it
because the marriage is Honorable among
all
remember Hebrews 13 verse 4 says let
marriage be held in honor among all and
let the marriage bed be undefiled for
God will judge the sexually immoral and
adulterous
you need to understand that marriage is
not just how it's marriage it is
important because marriage between a man
and a woman
also symbolizes our relationship with
God
listen to this
Ephesians 5 22 wives submit to your own
husbands as to the Lord for the husband
is the head of the wife even as Christ
is the head of the church his body and
is himself its savior
now as the church submits to Christ
so also wives should submit in
everything to their husbands
let me just quickly pause here because a
lot of guys think that they are the boss
wow I'm the head of the family no you
don't understand what it means that
Christ is the head of the church leading
it in a loving way in a truthful way but
also sacrificing his own life for the
church he also said that he came to
serve
so if you lead your wife gently in love
to obey God's word then she needs to
listen to Because ultimately then she
listens to God's word but if you lead
her and you say she's got to do things
that are in contrast with scripture she
doesn't need to listen to she needs to
listen to God
but if you gently lead her
you're not the boss you're a leader and
if you do so in love and in truth
according to scripture she will follow
you
because ultimately she's following God
verse 25 husbands love your wives as
Christ loved the church and gave himself
up for her that he might sanctify her
having cleansed her by the washing of
water with the word
so that he might present the church to
himself in splendor without spot or
wrinkle or any such thing that she might
be holy and without blemish
in the same way husbands should love
their wives as their own bodies he who
loves his wife loves himself for no one
ever hated his own flesh but nourishes
and cherishes it just as Christ does the
church because we are members of his
body therefore a man shall leave his
father and mother and hold fast to his
wife and the two shall become one flesh
this mystery is profound and I'm saying
that it refers to Christ and the church
however Let each one of you love his
wife as himself and let the wife see
that she respects her husband
now let me make this clear the reason
why so many people today want to have
sex in the wrong way is because they are
against God
their fleshly sinful nature wants to do
sin and sin is rebelling against God
it's a disease and this disease is in
all of us
Romans 3 verse 23 says for all have
sinned and fall short of the glory of
God
this sin affects your mind the
intellectual life of men this is why so
many men cannot understand the things of
God
until they give their lives to Christ
and the Holy Spirit reveals the truth of
the Bible to you
2 Corinthians 4 verse 4 says in their
case the God of this world has blinded
the minds of the unbelievers
to keep them from seeing the light of
the Gospel
of the glory of Christ who ears the
image of God
sin affects your whole life because it
separates you from God your body is
alive but your soul your spirit is dead
to the things of God and you do not
understand it because your your mind is
darkened and this is the reason why so
many men out there do not find real Joy
real peace
they try with things like sex with
different women but they will never be
satisfied always hungry for more and
maybe they go to other things like money
drugs alcohol
and even games
you do these things because you try to
escape
you try to forget
but you can't
that's why it is a chase after
nothingness
a chase after your own tail because we
were created to have fellowship with God
and if you don't have fellowship with
God you will never have peace
that is why you have this void
this emptiness inside of you you try to
fill it with temporary things
but it cannot fill you
temporary material things of this world
cannot fill you you need the Eternal you
need the spirit of God himself
this is why you see these celebrities
who are so empty they're just selling
sex all the time but they are so empty
why you would think that they have it
all together right they have Fame they
have riches they have luxury they have
everything that this world can give them
and yet they are empty
most of them are miserable depressed
they have one divorce after the other
addicted to drugs and the list just goes
on as because they are spiritually dead
separated from God and it is only God
that can make you spiritually alive
it will give you that kind of water
where you will never thirst again
that's what Jesus meant when he said
John 4 13 everyone who drinks of this
water will be thirsty again but whoever
drinks of the water that I will give him
will never be thirsty again the water
that I will give him will become in him
the spring of water welling up to
eternal life
if you are dead to the things of God but
you want to know you want to understand
you're thirsty
if you want to know more then please
watch these videos here
so that you will have water
and never thirst again
I'll see you there and always remember
life is short
so don't waste yours
bye